Well, good evening is so good to see all your faces.
So glad that you were here. There's quite
a few groups of us joining on a Wednesday
night. And so the students are here some
of the kids all the way down to kindergarten if
you have kids that are Pre-K and
under I just want to let you know that there is child
care available for them if you need that and so we can
give you space to be able to go and take your
kid over there if you need it, but I wanted to frame tonight
for all of us. I want us to understand why
we are here tonight.
This is a night of worship. And so
what is worship and what
is not worship so tonight Worship Is
Us?
In a continuation of our life of worship coming
here to sing together as a
church body.
and to worship
our creator
and what an honor it is for us to come here tonight to
be able to do that.
worship is
Songs right, but what it's not
is not just songs.
And I think it's important for us to know that songs are just
a vehicle for us as a church to be able to sing God's truth.
There are incredibly good servant that
God gives us to be able to sing his truth.
And so worship is songs, but it's not just that.
Then the other thing I want to remind us of is that sometimes we
all have our preferences of what songs we
should sing.
And shouldn't sing and I just ask tonight that even in
my own heart that we would just lay those things down and we would be
here to be about Jesus Christ
and to sing the truth to him
and praise him.
And so worship is lifting up our voices and singing.
What worship is not Is Us?
Listening to God's truth and only taking that in and
letting it be informational.
It's actually something that's formational for us.
But also it's something that we express.
And so when we sing and we hear God's truth, it's
something that should stir our affections for him.
And excite our hearts as a church body together, so tonight
I ask you invite you.
To be here tonight to sing God's truth and not
just a firm God's truth. But also allow
that truth to stir your heart and
your mind to praise him to honor
him with your heart.
And so right now I'm gonna ask you to stand and I'm
going to ask God to help us tonight to do that together.
So would you pray with me?
Father we come tonight with open hands.
This night is yours.
Whatever we came in with.
Whether there was traffic.
wrangling kids
maybe there was moments of pain.
Maybe there is.
Apathy in our hearts as we walked through these doors, but I
pray that so we walk through these doors tonight. We would encounter you.
We would encounter you our creator.
Because we're eager.
For you to move in our hearts and do what only you can
do.
But I know that there's parts of our hearts that can
easily drift off into thought and to other things.
Would you sinner us but you grab our attention?
Would we leave space for you tonight?
We allow you to make room in our hearts.
And by your spirit would we invest fully
into what's happening tonight?
God help us not waste a moment.
and win
my heart
our hearts don't feel
a word or a moment to help us because
he prays that we are going to lift up tonight.
You're worthy of that.
We lay aside what we're expecting.
We give this all to you because it's yours.
Father I pray that you would inhabit the Praises of
your people tonight.
Lay your burdens down.
If you're
willing put your hands out in front of you as a
symbol to give to him.
sign of your surrender to him
every burden
every
this is my surrender.
Where I lay down every line
every time.
This is my Sur.
Render, and I will make room for you.
To do whatever
you want.
Whatever you want.
And I will make room.
To whatever you want to
whatever you
want.
Here is where I lay it down
every burden every
Crown. This is my
surrender.
This is my surrender.
Here is where I lay it down
every lion every day.
do whatever you
here
you
your way you
do whatever you
to
and I will make
for you
to do whatever you
want to do whatever you
want and I will make for you.
to do whatever you
Want so do whatever you want to.
hear
this is my
Surrender, this is my spirit.
Here is where I lay down
every
This is my surrender.
God we confess that your way is better.
if we try
that we have made on our own we tend to always fail.
God would you show us the airway? It's infinitely
better than yours.
Just sing This Together your way is better.
You always better.
Your way is better.
In your ways better we confess
that you always better.
He always better.
In your ways better in your
way is better.
Week as I was praying for this night.
God brought Psalm 139 to mind.
As we think about how we were created.
How we should go about our lives?
This Psalm should inform us how we should live
and it's because he's the one that made us
and so we didn't make ourselves.
Obviously he made us.
And so I want to read this for us and I'm gonna even emphasize
moments in it.
You let this psalm.
Affect your heart right now.
Oh Lord. You've searched me.
Known me.
every physical action
you know when I sit down, you know when I Rise Up
you discern my thoughts from afar.
You searched out my path and my lying
down and are acquainted with all of my
ways.
Even before a word is on my tongue and
behold. Oh Lord, you know it all together.
You hit me in behind and before and you
let your hand upon me.
The fact that he knows us this well.
This should.
Stun us. That's why the
response is such knowledge is too wonderful for me.
Cannot attain it.
so like John said
where am I going to go except for with you? So where shall
I go from your spirit?
Where shall I free from your presence?
If I ascended to Heaven you're there if I
make my bed and Shield or hell you're there, too.
If I take the wings of the morning and dwell in the utmost parts
of the sea, even there your hands should lead
me and your right hand shall hold me.
And if I say surely the darkness shall cover
me in the light about me be night. Even the
darkness is not.
It's not dark to you. The night is bright as the
day.
For darkness is as light with you.
So there is no where we can go without our
creator knowing us.
How comforting is that?
and then he tells us even how we're formed so he
knows not only who we are where we are what we're doing, but he
also knows
he knows our past present and future so you formed
me in my inward parts of kids. God formed
you and your mommy.
Isn't that amazing?
He formed my inward Parts. You knitted me together in my
mother's womb. So I praise you for I'm
fearfully and wonderfully made wonderful or
your works.
My soul knows it very well. My frame was
not hidden from you when I was being made in
secret and intricately woven and the depths
of the earth your eyes saw my unformed substance
in your book were written every one
of them the days that were formed for me.
When is yet? There was none of them.
Say this back.
Precious to me or your thoughts
of God. How vast is the sum of them? If I
could count them. They're more than the sand.
I awake and I'm still with you.
And so when we sing a song that says I want to make a room for God
in my life. I want to surrender. This is what I do. It's because of
this it's because he created us he
knows better than me and he knows way better
than all of us put together. He knows
us. So let's let him lead us surrender should
be our response to that. And so
let's sing.
The song I surrender all to him.
Oh.
Jesus
Sur
round
All to him I free please.
I Surrender
here
to see my
blessed savior.
Jesus
Take me.
you
see my place it
saved you.
Oh to Jesus
I Surrender make
me Jesus.
that
he
sees
to in
I will love and
Trust in his presence
daily.
you
oh to see.
My place it saves you.
you
oh Tuesday.
My place it saves you.
We sing.
That forget they're all.
I am I give it back.
to you Lord
in light of someone 3
y not made us, you know us, you know, when we sit down
we'll rise up you just turn our
thoughts.
You search us out you search on my path.
So I give all to you.
all I am
no.
I I
give it back.
every breath
every day
Oh I am.
back
to
every every breath
could I
you
Are worthy you are worthy.
of all blessing and honor and Glory
you
of all blessing and daughter
you are worthy.
you are
of blessing and honoring
you are words.
Jesus your
worthy of our broken parts.
God given to you.
Do you feel the world is?
Broken, do you feel the Shadows deep?
into you know that all the dark won't stop
the light from
getting to
Do you wish that you could see?
It All Me
is all creation girl.
What is a new creation coming?
And is the glory of the Lord to
Be The Light Within?
our
Is good that we remind ourselves?
It's anyone Worthy. Is anyone
is anyone
able to break the seal and
open the
Score it's the lying on you.
conquer the gray
Davis rude
he
ard of all blessing and honored
Tears just the
father truly love.
you
And it's Jesus our Messiah. Oh
forever those he loves.
To our god intend to dwell again
with us.
here
for light of Judah
Who conquered the gray? He's Davis
rude and the lamb who
dies on the sea from
every people and try.
honor and blue
he
would of all blessing and honor and
glue
We know the answer Lord. We know
you were here.
you
of all blessing and honor and Glory
Just sing that again. You're worthy you are
you?
of all blessing and honoring
you all can be seated.
Looking as we as you're saying that song we're
gonna look into.
God's word and
look into the throne room in heaven. Like we just
sang Jesus is Worthy lamb.
slain for our sin and we're gonna
take a moment to to give him glory give
him honor give him power for his
created all things. I want to read the scripture for us.
It's the picture into the the throne room in heaven.
It's Revelation 4 9 whenever the
living creatures give glory and honor and thanks
to him who is Seated on the throne who lives?
forever and ever who
24 Elders fall down before him
Seated on the throne
And worship him.
Who lives forever and ever?
And they cast their crowns Before the Throne.
They say worthy. Are you our Lord
and God to receive Glory?
and honor and Power
by your will the existed
in all things are created and
we're in the first week of a new year.
and we
were gathered here together.
Tell Jesus he is worthy.
so what we want to do this evening is just take
a few minutes and just tell him he's worthy.
of whatever comes Whatever May Come
whatever has come in our lives that he is worthy
of all glory all honor.
and Power
and I'll guide us through a few
moments, but just take a moment. There's 30 seconds or so to tell
Jesus.
Worthy the lamb slain.
for our sin
So we do that we we saw that the elders cashed
their crowns Before the
Throne and what?
here today, but we may have things that we
we're expecting we have plants and we
have plans for 2023.
What if what would it look like?
streaming here if we
cast those Before the Throne
this he told Jesus.
Whatever happens whatever whatever whichever way
this goes.
Three I want to give you.
glory honor and Power
No matter what. My plants may be maybe.
no matter how my job goes in 2023
how
what my family looks like at the
end of this year that we
would still hold to that truth that he's
worthy over.
Just take a moment to
cast that before his feet
simple chorus together
all glory
all honor
all power to the land who is
slain.
no glory
How we tear the
land?
Who was?
no glory
No power.
On it.
to the
same all glory
all on it.
all parity
no glory
on
it all power.
To you know all
glory.
to the
Moon
Of power to you. We're gonna
hang out here for all glory all glory.
You explain?
power to
you
Stand together we're gonna magnify Jesus who
he is.
Submit Our Lives to him.
Here were creation
certainly articulate.
The third tongues to
lift one.
from
north side
and East we'd hear
Christ be magnified.
Where's the holiest echoing
is easy?
Name burst from
seeing sky from the
greatest.
Oh Christ be magnified.
Let it praise her eyes
Christ being magnified in
me.
magnified from
the ocean
When Every
Creature finds it's
in most Melody.
Free human heart is needed
Christ.
I won't bow down to you
stand strong and worship you.
If it puts me in the fire, I'll
reach your voice because you're there too.
Now won't be for my feelings.
you
inside
Eyes be right inside.
then Christ
be mad.
Oh Christ be magnified.
Oh fell down to you stand strong
in worship you if it
puts me in the fire.
Rejoice because you're there too.
I won't be for my feelings.
stream 95 from here
Christ being
magnified
Jesus we long for that.
long for you to be praised Above All Things
as you are over all things.
So we sing this last song.
Just to tell you that you're over everything to acknowledge
that not that you don't already know that but from your
people we are proclaiming.
From your church. We are proclaiming.
Jesus you're over everything.
all the fear
will change
over
all anxiety
over troubles and all pain
over sickness and disease you
Reign on
the throne. I'll praise
to you.
one name over
over Death and All
sin
over hell over the grave Darkness
vowels and demons fully
mention of your name
as you Reign on the throne.
O praise to you one name
over everything.
Guess you Rain Jesus.
He came from Glory.
Took on flesh to save the Lost.
grace and mercy
It's played upon the cross our Redemption.
He's the Hope For All Mankind one
name over everything.
one name over
everything sing his name again.
Our Song for only
Jesus Christ is
can arrival
Horizon he came
in one moment. He brought
dancing.
he
Jesus
just
You Jesus
Christ.
We thank
you for being over
all these things.
one day
freezing hearings for
ever
All right.
Over everything we can trust you.
We sing this simple song to you.
To just voice our trust in you Jesus.
Is so sweet.
trust in
Jesus just to take him out
his word.
and just to rest
upon his
from just
to know the Sith
Lord Jesus Jesus how
I trust him
how I proved
him.
Jesus
praise. Oh for Grace.
To trust him.
Jesus Jesus
This Grace God over Grace. Oh for
Grace to trust.
him Jesus as we
leave this room tonight.
Would you shower Your Grace on us?
To trust you more with our lives.
to surrender
at every step
and to see how worthy you are and how worth
our lives you are.
Jesus we love you.
Pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
a church here dismissed